Tollan the capital of Estonia the
government's clear long term foreign
policy is oriented towards the west NATO
membership and EU accession it's a
country with a northern European
identity but also with a Soviet past
estonia's highest-ranking soldier sees
the entire region under threat from
Russia they have multiplied conventional
military forces on the borders of
Western Europe near the borders of
Estonia Latvia and Lithuania they've
created a new tank army and new
divisions and are going back to the old
Cold War era military structures and
they are not neglecting threatening
nuclear gestures Estonia's Armed Forces
number around 6,000 we joined three
members of the Estonian Border Agency on
a patrol their job is to guard the
country's territorial waters which
involves close cooperation with the
military the narva reservoir in the
northeast of the country also marks the
border to Russia it's just across the
way under current circumstances the
Patrol even stops seemingly harmless
fishing boats
as you can see the Norfolk Otter
reservoir is quite large but the border
is just a line some accidentally cross
it May 9th Moscow's Red Square the
annual commemoration of Russia's victory
over Nazi Germany thousands of soldiers
wait for the military parade to start in
recent years the event has become a
major military show again parking back
to Soviet times this is the stage for
Russia to display its resurgent military
prowess under President Vladimir Putin's
watch the Russian Armed Forces have
undergone comprehensive modernization
but such appeal to the Soviet era is at
odds with Moscow's modern cosmopolitan
image the editor-in-chief of a
government friendly journal warns
against hasty comparisons we can say
that the spirit is back but in fact it's
very simplistic explanation what we have
now has different nature and different
routes peace and security in Europe is a
big issue in southern Germany too in the
state of Bavaria some residents here
have got up extra early to spruce up
their community while 1,400 American
soldiers and 400 military vehicles are
on their way from their Bavarian base to
Eastern Europe crossing the bridge is
the first step in an operation dubbed
Dragoon ride after the nickname for the
regiment united we stand is the message
to America's friends in Europe as the
troops head off to Estonia they to show
off their military strength as a
deterrent says their commander US
colonel John Mayer
it demonstrates the United States Army
in Europe's ability and capability to
rapidly move I'll help prevent any type
of hostilities we are not in the Cold
War situation where you know hundreds of
thousands of troops were masked up along
the borders with nuclear weapons and we
all really feared or afraid of a big war
between the Soviet Union and NATO in the
United States the challenge now is that
we are experiencing experiences many
more uncertainties via cheslav Nikonov
is on the campaign trail in Nizhny
Novgorod he's a supporter of Putin's
party and the president of a foundation
that promotes Russian culture abroad he
has no doubts about who is to blame for
the crisis and relations with the West
it's primarily due to American policy
NATO is a tool of the u.s. it serves
American global dominance the United
States will do everything to cement its
global domination which includes trying
to weaken alternative centres of powers
such as Russia Germany also plans to
send combat troops to the Baltic on
temporary deployments these battle tanks
have been decommissioned but now the
government is buying back mothballed
tanks from the manufacturer and
modernizing them by 2017 around a
hundred of them are to be back in
service after German reunification
Berlin steadily reduced its troop
strength but in a policy u-turn 7,000
personnel are to be added to the German
armed forces a quarter century of
military downsizing appears to be
history